[Música]
al menos 19 personas resultaron heridas
en un ataque perpetrado en una iglesia
católica en la ciudad de makassar en las
islas célebes en indonesia el gobierno
calificó este hecho como un acto
terrorista la policía local afirmó que
identificó a los dos atacantes uno de
ellos habría participado en un acto
similar en filipinas en 2018
en mi amar tuvieron lugar los funerales
de algunas de las 114 víctimas que
dejaron los enfrentamientos entre los
militares y los ciudadanos que rechazan
el golpe militar la comunidad
internacional criticó la represión de
las fuerzas armadas mientras que
naciones unidas señaló a los militares
de estar perpetrando asesinatos masivos
y varias manifestaciones fueron
convocadas en francia en vísperas de la
presentación y el posterior estudio del
llamado proyecto de ley del clima y
resiliencia en la asamblea nacional la
propuesta contempla un centenar de
iniciativas para luchar contra el cambio
climático a pesar de que algunos grupos
ambientalistas en francia lo consideran
insuficiente
muy buenas tardes gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en las noticias de france
24 soy santiago lópez gonzález estamos
en vivo desde nuestros estudios en
bogotá en colombia vamos a comenzar en
indonesia con los últimos reportes
relacionados con el ataque que tuvo
lugar en una iglesia católica en la
ciudad de makassar las más recientes
informaciones indican que serían unas 19
personas las que resultaron heridas
después de este fuerte estallido
perpetrado por dos atacantes mientras
era celebrada allí un servicio religioso
los hechos ocurrieron en las islas
célebes en pleno inicio de la semana
santa para el mundo católico el
presidente de indonesia a yoko hui todo
calificó este hecho como un acto
terrorista la policía local confirmó
haber identificado a los dos atacantes
aparentemente uno de ellos estaría
involucrado también en un ataque similar
perpetrado en el sur de filipinas en el
sobre el acto de perro en la puerta de
entrada de la catedral una casa lo
condenó 'enérgicamente' he dado las
instrucciones al jefe de policía para
que arranque de raíz esa red terrorista
banca ha puesto a la gente a mantener la
calma y garantizó la seguridad de
nuestra gente para realizar actividades
religiosas libremente y sin niño en
canarias y en mi amar tuvieron lugar los
funerales de algunos de los 114
fallecidos que dejaron los choques entre
los militares y los ciudadanos en las
más recientes manifestaciones de parte
de los ciudadanos contra el golpe de
estado los medios locales han llamado a
estas recientes víctimas como estrellas
caídas y sus funerales tuvieron lugar en
diferentes ciudades del país de otra
parte la comunidad internacional entre
ellos la unión europea y también eeuu
han condenado la muerte de este centenar
de personas y han rechazado la represión
por parte de los militares la
organización de las naciones unidas
indicó que la junta militar está
efectuando asesinatos en masa
entre las víctimas hay menores de edad
después de una sangrienta represión que
mató a más de 100 manifestantes
antigolpistas la comunidad internacional
ha rechazado las acciones de la junta de
mianmar jefes militares de una docena de
países incluidos eeuu reino unido
australia y japón condenaron el uso
letal de la violencia en una rara
declaración conjunta un ejército
profesional sigue las normas
internacionales de conducta y es
responsable de proteger no de dañar a
las personas a las que sirven los
embajadores de la unión europea en
mianmar incluidos francia y españa-
también pidieron conjuntamente a la
junta que dimitiera describiendo las
acciones del ejército birmano como
inmorales e indefendibles la onu condenó
igualmente los asesinatos el secretario
de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken denunció la violencia en
su cuenta en twitter estamos
horrorizados por el derramamiento de
sangre perpetrado por las fuerzas de
seguridad birmanas que demuestra que la
junta sacrificar a la vida de la gente
para servir a unos pocos envió mi más
sentido pésame a las familias de las
víctimas el valiente pueblo de mianmar
rechaza el reino de terror de los
militares
el sábado fue el día más sangriento
desde que los militares destituyeron al
gobierno democráticamente electo del
país y entre los muertos había niños el
elevado número de fallecidos se produjo
en una jornada simbólicamente importante
el día anual de las fuerzas armadas que
se celebra con un gran desfile militar
este año asistió el viceministro de
defensa ruso y algunos representantes de
china tanto rusia como china han
bloqueado la condena del golpe de estado
en mianmar en el consejo de seguridad de
la onu hasta ahora más de 400
manifestantes a favor de la democracia
han sido asesinados desde que la junta
militar asumió el poder a principios de
febrero
nos vamos hasta europa en francia fueron
convocadas varias manifestaciones en la
víspera del examen del llamado proyecto
de ley del clima y resiliencia en la
asamblea nacional en parís la propuesta
legislativa refleja parte de las 149
propuestas de la convención ciudadana
por el clima
todos los científicos dicen que el
proyecto de ley que propone el gobierno
se queda corto no permitiría alcanzar
los objetivos del acuerdo de parís y por
eso es importante que seamos muchos
ciudadanos movilizándonos
para así presionar a los legisladores
que comenzarán a examinar el borrador a
partir del lunes para que propongan
enmiendas que hagan más ambicioso este
proyecto de ley que actualmente está
lejos de ser suficiente y de otra parte
en barcelona unas 5000 personas se
reunieron para un inusual evento masivo
en plena pandemia de kobe 19 se trata de
un ensayo de una posible nueva
normalidad que podría revivir la
industria del entretenimiento en vivo
desde la capital catalana nuestra
corresponsal el issga single estuvo en
este evento y nos da más detalles
cinco mil personas se olvidaban por
completo de la pandemia aquí en
barcelona anoche durante tres horas de
un concierto sin distancias de seguridad
en el concierto el llamado festival por
la cultura segura fue un experimento
científico muy serio autoridades locales
actores del mundo cultural y médicos
especializados en enfermedades
infecciosas colaboraron todos para hacer
lo posible y demostrar sobre todo que si
se puede organizar eventos de este tipo
en plena pandemia obviamente respetando
un protocolo sanitario estricto primero
todo el público tuvo que realizar un
test antígenos pocas horas antes del
concierto todos también tenían que
llevar una mascarilla fp2 durante todo
el concierto y finalmente la ventilación
estaba muy controlada durante el evento
finalmente tanto organizadores como
público y cantantes salieron muy
satisfechos
de este experimento un primer gran
concierto en europa y esperan a que más
que un punto de inflexión para poder
volver a organizar alguno en el futuro
en otros temas este lunes comenzará el
juicio contra derek chauvín el ex
oficial de policía acusado de la muerte
del ciudadano george floyd a quien
estaba quien tenía bajo su custodia y a
quien aparentemente asfixió al ponerle
su rodilla en el cuello para poderlo
reducir el hombre podría enfrentar una
condena de hasta 40 años de prisión
andrés meza muñón nos cuenta más
para muchos esta esquina de mineápolis
en eeuu es terreno sagrado para expresar
su indignación un sinnúmero de personas
llega a diario al lugar donde la
brutalidad policial acabó con la vida de
george floyd el 25 de mayo de 2020
el episodio fue la chispa que
desencadenó el movimiento mundial contra
el racismo más grande del siglo 21
durante 8 minutos y 46 segundos el
entonces policía derecho bin presionó su
rodilla contra el cuello de floyd quien
permanecía en el suelo esposado tras ser
arrestado por sospechas de entregar un
billete falso en una tienda una serie de
protestas tanto pacíficas como violentas
se tomaron estados unidos de costa a
costa y se extendieron hasta el día de
hoy aunque con menos intensidad los
manifestantes dieron fuerza al black
lights matter el movimiento que surgió
en 2013 y que fue creciendo a medida que
aumentaba el número de afroamericanos
muertos en manos de la policía
los disturbios saqueos y enfrentamientos
con la fuerza pública llevaron a las
autoridades a imponer toques de queda ya
desplegar la guardia nacional en varios
estados del país el tema causó una
profunda división en la sociedad
estadounidense las fronteras no
detuvieron el malestar por el caso floyd
y las protestas por el respeto a las
vidas afro llegaron a europa américa
latina áfrica y algunos países de medio
oriente se desató una ola de rechazo a
los símbolos relacionados con el
colonialismo y la esclavitud estatuas de
conquistadores y otros monumentos fueron
derribadas alrededor del mundo a casi un
año del primer aniversario del asesinato
de georg floyd la sed de justicia sigue
intacta y este lunes derecho bin será
juzgado por homicidio en segundo grado
homicidio en tercer grado y homicidio
involuntario de ser declarado culpable
enfrentaría hasta 40 años de prisión
otros ex oficiales que lo acompañaban a
que el 25 de mayo están acusados de
complicidad y se espera que sean
juzgados este verano pero más que una
condena la sociedad quiere que haya un
cambio en nombre de georg floyd y otros
que murieron bajo las mismas
circunstancias
se nos acaba el tiempo esto en las
noticias de france 24 buenas tardes
[Música]